but what I couldn't believe is that you
were a janitor for whoa look who did the
research what was that like being a
janitor [__] stalker yeah
well done sir are those Warby Parker I
believe so yeah me too it's all I wear
fetty
um
oh yeah janitor actually you know
janitor sounds like a rough gig it was a
great gig headphones in nobody told me
what to do it's a labor you don't have
to use your brain so I just thought of
jokes all day or I listened to podcasts
all day it was great I janitor where a
New York City the hedge fund like in a
skyscraper and I was in charge of four
or five floors so I'd have to move
People's Furniture I had to you know
clean the bathrooms it'd be a big old
Bowl miscarriage in there and I had to
clean that out and then uh you know it'd
be like a possum and the aviation Ducks
I had to get that out it had its bad
parts but I take that over like a desk
job any day